i'll ask you
some questions from professors first and
then we'll get on to general audience
questions
okay professor rebecca goldstein a
professor of philosophy
she asks i would love to hear noam
chomsky expatiate
on what he thinks the implications of
girdle's incompleteness theorems are
both in terms of mathematical realism
and
in terms of our mathematically knowing
minds
i don't think there's any clearer answer
to that question
i mean the technical aspects of the
theorem are understood means
within a particular language of
sufficient richness you can't
establish the truth of expressions
within that language
what the significant it means that
there's going to be
if you want to establish truth you're
going to have to keep going up in a
endless hierarchy of richer and richer
languages
but we can understand it
so it's comprehensible so that's as far
as our understanding goes
but what it tells us about the word the
anything outside about the world is
really goes back to the question a much
simpler question
what does arithmetic tell us about the
world
where are the numbers uh they're not in
our minds
there are truths about the numbers just
plain natural numbers
which we somehow grasp but what are the
things
that they're uh that we're grasping
is it something in a platonic universe
is it something in a mental construction
i don't think they're any satisfying
answers to these questions
are there any implications from girdles
incompleteness theorems to linguistics
no i don't think so i mean there are
linguistics does involve a formal
computational systems
but they're sufficiently elementary so
that these questions don't arise
and if they did it wouldn't matter so
they arise in physics which uses all of
mathematics but
doesn't interfere with the physicist